yeah hello welcome to our new Monday
livestream the first one by the ICC here
on YouTube yeah but not so first on
YouTube but the first that I'm doing via
YouTube ok I hope everything works all
right yeah with this new format i think
it should it should work so um yeah
hello also to all of you in the chat
yeah we also have a new layout i hope
you all like it it looks a little bit
better i think then we what we hope you
had before the green screen is also
working quite fine i believe it looks
much better than than before um what you
have to see is that the clocks are no on
the left hand side we have got the white
and black clock it takes a moment to get
used to but it is a rather um yea rather
logical kind of setup I believe ok so
any questions um a good resource on the
leningrad dutch for players around 1800
yes I've got one the diamond touch by
moskalenko that's a good book it has all
the Dutch lines not just the Leningrad
and it's very interesting event of book
um no I don't play the selectors laugh
or the dwelling endgame I'm sorry ok I'm
going to start a five-minute game I
haven't played a game today so I'm happy
to get some blitz kamsin yeah hello to
New York
yeah hope all of you um have found the
way let's say he to the stream or the
regular twitch on Twitch people through
G audience okay um let's get going here
playing Michael age that's Michael
Hennigan I think from the UK he's been
the English champion I believe long time
ago but currently I think I'm retired or
maybe maybe is a casual play and four
nations chess league or something like
that but it's not regular tournament
player the King's gambit mmm I don't
think so I'll stick with my usual stuff
okay so we get some kind of Kings
engineer the the diamond touch has has
everything you need yes I think the brea
with black hair that's doable I think
okay um age for here is there something
with b5 coming hmm might be but I have
g5 so hmm he's going a for interesting
hmm okay i think i'll try to close down
the kingside this is so promising if you
can get it in that I tried to do it he
does not have to play g5 but most black
players some still lower than he doesn't
okay it's threatening Knight takes e4
hmm that's wow that's oh ha strong I
think I've made this mistake before now
that I think of it
huh sure kg5 he's threatening a
three-year that's the issue and if I was
attacked a really bad position already
here that's not good at all ah very bad
the dining with Dutch is a very
aggressive opening but you cannot really
say what is the positional opening the
Leningrad is aggressive but it's not
it's not so tactical @ same yes that's
true you cannot see the ratings so we
probably have to have to change that
yeah black will play a 3 i'm not quite
sure what he's thinking about maybe he's
got something stronger with a 3 it just
looks good for black yeah you're right
you don't see the ratings we have to
change that this is a new new setup and
I was tryna around a little bit we have
to probably adjust that a little bit so
i think the rating ratings are good to
see he's rated 2227 the sky yeah now I
have to play this this terrible Quincy
one move yeah we will address that but I
don't want to change something during
the show
yeah I see we can we can definitely
improve on that I'm happy that he took
on d5 unless I'm overlooking something
of course because now night c 4 comes
comes back into the list of options here
well there's a black space on the left
hand side are you actually right yeah
there's something that will be checked
okay I'm happy that my opponent is not
putting punishing me to the fullest here
I think that would have been possible
I'm I still don't like my position but
okay I think I'm asking him about this
can I just take the pawn what new
background it looks different yeah we've
changed the layout here the ICC layout
it is not that has got nothing to do
with my upcoming move it's a it's a
green screen in working yeah I grabbed a
pawn and hope for the best yeah it's
supposed to look like a plank of wood so
i can take on c3 mmm take an odd but
that is closed Bishop g4 ever might work
yeah 91 loses stuff what a bad position
rook h8 takes on c3 oka takes on be
tuned oh my goodness what a bad game
I don't even have a moose that I can
play I mean I see that I'm lost but I
don't even see a move that I can play
wow
yeah he's taking this of course it
doesn't help I'm just lost
let's see I mean he can play whatever
really
now yet threatened some discoveries so
I'm continuing a little bit even though
it is really not a position that gives
me much hope
yeah yeah recover from a string of
losses it's always difficult if you if
you're saying your losses were against
strong opponents it's sometimes a lot of
bad idea to simply to try to play some
some weaker ones just get a little bit
of confidence back and hope and hope you
do do better well amazing but what to do
after this game for example yeah you can
kill me with Queen f2 it's very easy
actually yeah okay wow that was a plate
is like a complete beginner very bad I
don't don't understand why the stream
wasn't easy to find I even added a
button in the video itself so it should
work I think if you if you subscribe to
the YouTube channel of the ICC um and
then what helps well okay JC areas and
then below 2400 that always feels bad so
let's see if I can get back to that I
mean if I'm if I'm getting below 2300 I
feel like yeah someone as i know i would
be really bad and below 24 is also not
great so let's see and now this guy
plays the most boring line ever yeah
this is really uh turley boring
well okay
I think age six but oh is this the
position where you can take and play 23
yes and I will stumble into into
kindergarten tactics I hate this stuff
yes I forget this line and the only line
that is really dangerous for black yeah
what the heck
I don't even remember why it works and
because they can take them that's the
most harmless opening ever for ideas
it's just this one trick and I'll
stumble into it great great yeah okay
anyway
yes I'm stressed yeah because I'm moving
and it is it's a pain in the ass it
really is a pain a total pain can't
Kendra I'm not really relaxed yeah I
have to say but I do my best yeah okay
training Queens when you have two phones
down it's not exactly great
ok check me on age 7 that's not exactly
great but my position is so bad drinking
a couple of BS I don't know I don't want
to promote echo all on streams it's no
it's no solution really isn't now what
about this go here I play he will play
Queen g3 probably trade queens or
something
he doesn't even want to trade Queens
aren't you afraid of my mighty bishop
blitz and beer as probably not such a
show I mean but I think Simon William
says show us close to Blitzen beer maybe
blitz and whiskey or something jam and a
position is unfortunately so bad that
you cannot really screw it up
yeah mmm a couple of couple of things
here night c4 check and this one now
anyway I will still continue someone who
plays that boring an opening it's often
possible to fail so I'm trying even
though the position is of course
completely lost
yeah it will be on YouTube em we think
that this is the better the better
platform this is the first of hopefully
many many shows to come
now I won't resign this absolutely not
it is lost but i still can continue this
position i'm still reasonably active
here so there is no real need to resign
I can especially try to remove the pawns
forward so this is what I'm trying the D
point in particular event III now what
are you doing here I don't know I just
push this see what happens
hmm as long as I've got some some kind
of idea here I'm not resigning so what
is your idea look these six so okay
ok
hmm
yeah you know it remains lost but it's
lost for a very long time and is not
really doing the utmost to kill me off I
always found something again yeah what a
terrible game so let's end this them and
win a game yeah that's really
frustrating okay playing light like and
that's not an easy opponent that's
international master Martin it's Martin
right some Xander German I am so let's
see what I can do in this game I really
need to stop that two losses in a row is
pretty awful so yeah let's go 93 m
openings for wide that lead to a
checking play but don't require heavy
theory well no it's very difficult very
really very difficult to do you mean you
can play things that might lead to
attacking play but you cannot force that
anyway if your opponent plays in a very
sound and solid way how are you going to
get an attack I mean you can only get in
to check if they play something that is
kind of yeah that is very provocative
let's say yeah and if they play
something sound and solid you never get
an attack anywhere which of the
candidates for the presidential election
in the u.s. do our support um oh I have
no clear answer I have a pretty good
idea who I don't support I think all of
the Republican Party candidates are
that's just amazing I mean no words but
I have no idea which one of the
Democrats I would support I have not
really am I don't have a clear idea what
Bernie Sanders is doing for example is I
understand this that is a mmm and that
his um um yeah more more more over yeah
but why would you call it on the left
side part of the the political spectrum
but i cannot i don't really have any
clear idea what is what he supports or
things like that so um i have no idea
about him so what now that shouldn't be
so bad hmm what to do here hmm i don't
like that he plays before even though
that isn't a bad thing I think so let's
do this
yeah I don't know I don't know all of
them I owned I don't know all of the
Republican candidates i mostly know
Trump and that guy cruise I mean they
they they have to be put in loony bin
that's the only only thing that you can
do with those people but other than that
I have no idea
ok so this position isn't very I have no
clear idea what to do yeah we can put
some pressure there it's not it's not a
big problem but the problem is i cannot
play 92 because of afore here hmm i have
no square hmm wow that's very very
unfortunate
Wow I don't have a move here I'm really
in bad shape again I cannot go 92 here
hmm and taking only five this is really
bad I mean I have to I have to but the
position is really bad I have played
this far too superficially
awful absolutely awful Wow
yeah i won my recent league game my game
yesterday in a very nice way actually
and this ball because I suppose we'll
get a video on my channel so I actually
can play relatively decent at the moment
but ok um yeah my opponent wants to play
Bishop with eight and that check is what
he wants to do you should fa does 94
let's go here Kings gambit I can play a
form i can do if i don't don't mind that
I just don't like to play something
totally crazy that that's losing like
the Latvian also my night there I've got
a bad night bad bishops are a problem
but bad nights thats it's even worse I
don't see how to get that back into the
game
pretty awful yeah it's not it's not so
easy for me to comment upon some of the
presidential candidates in the US I
simply don't know the person's I mean
you're in Germany you get some info of
course but you don't get that many
details and especially you don't learn
about the less the less prominent ones
let's say are the ones that are behind
in the in the in the polls so wow I
really hate them hate this position my
night never gets a good square then down
to 35 seconds this is the worst
I where d 4 is a good move now for him
it doesn't see her poo now he might now
have some kind of psycho sacrifice but
at least I can play Knight c3 if I can
get the Knights amor back into this game
then I might not be lost but tweenage
three Bishop g3 my twin really possible
yeah I am of course it wins it decides
it's just a terrible position
hmm i think i'm not sure am I losing
here maybe but I think he had it could
have played that much stronger but i'm
down to a couple of seconds now it's got
four pawns there are four pawns is a bit
too much
I just wants to win on time we know the
story yeah okay well this was a terrible
game so just related career options for
players between two thousand and two
thousand three hundred armed you can
definitely teach especially in schools
you don't need to be a super super
strong player to do that that that's
that's an option for sure um and you can
also you can also write for sure the
first human player to reach 3000 rating
ads is that the players not born yet
very very likely okay I'm trying to go
for Kings engineer and let's see maybe
this can help let's just go for a tech
and see what happens
oh really that why is that possibly even
let's take it
a groom felt yeah I can take and
playground failure will probably be
entertaining to watch as I don't really
know it that opening well but we'll see
okay you sacrifice a pawn that's it's an
interesting interesting option and yet
another pawn for Bishop c4 hmm set
really that much of a threat I'm
threatening this now take his night okay
so let's see what happens here my
opponent really wants me to win but that
doesn't mean that I actually managed to
do so okay so I cannot go there and does
he have now this is unbelievable he
didn't plan any of it he just blundered
that that piece and now that is actually
somewhat working for him oh my goodness
what a day and yeah I have no squares I
have no square cm Queen a3 is got Bishop
before Queen B to Roxy to maybe I can go
to deform great stuff
you
yeah I think I think I'm my queen I
couldn't sacrifice the Queen yeah it
wasn't exactly a great day after same as
i mentioned i'm going to move to a new
place in a couple of weeks three weeks
and absolutely everything that is
related to the whole thing costs about
two to three times as much as originally
was was believed today I think the
estimate costs today rice by like
fifteen hundred euros or something for
basically a staff of nonsense that has
to be done however and it gets more
expensive and more expensive by day yeah
that was difficult to find yeah first
you blunder everything and then you have
to find those it takes ages to find the
kitty moose okay I'm going here my queen
yeah hello to meat grinder and all the
others yeah well maybe it's not so easy
to catch the Queen looks it to Queen D
for loop t to Quincy for what are you
doing now okay I'm going here the only
thing okay this one so if I now go King
g7 what is happening here ninety-seven
rookie seven should work
you
what a funky position yea my queen where
is my queen going nowhere I guess ah
Jesus 95 but does that help probably not
much
I get some stuff for the Queen at least
now you have to take the Queen buddy
what's the alternative here I don't see
it oh so Queen III you again you want to
try to I have Bishop f5 here in this
position right counter attacking or not
let's go let's go hey ho let's go that's
the ramones right I'm keeping this piece
mr. I belong to us so what now and queen
here yeah i'll also flag him i guess but
I I don't mind to just win the game if
possible how to do that night a4 attack
the Queen and it doesn't have much
anywhere to go right to a one I guess
resins stopped it stopped it okay yeah
somehow my queen didn't get lost don't
know how it should should have happened
but still I'm down more than 40 points
in that session which shirts yeah okay
next game I'll play one year form and go
for something blood blood ya somethin
somethin weird
yeah I don't get a game what the beep
they are quite clean has to go to a 10
my favorite classic a card game oh I
don't know I had a coupla at Donkey Kong
and pac-man and stuff like that I never
played Super Mario which is I guess many
people's favorite physical condition is
very important for a chess player I
don't work out and this is a problem
this is on my to do list after four
after when I've got settled in in my new
place so let's try to Castle long
quickly against the French and do
something yeah I couldn't do the Kings
gambit why most chess players of the top
chess players are physically quite fit
it's the wrong idea I mean really the
Carlton is super fit yeah around yarn
that's all cool they are all very very
physically fit I didn't make a video to
refute the pond siani I don't think this
is possible the poinciana isn't great
but it is not a terribly bad opening
okay how bad is this however when I'm
playing here is that really really bad
it might be but it it is it is kind of
interesting
yeah the Apple watch just have fitness
features I do stuff it's not like I'm
not trying to do something about my
fitness but currently around with all
that stuff with with my move I don't
really have the time I don't find the
time whatever and what the beep what is
this Knight f6 you can take that look
strange and smooth I mean okay my heart
set up look strange but hmm okay why
would a roni I'll be the david beckham
of chess that sounds weird
I mean uronian has won a couple of
tournaments like beckham never won
anything maybe a couple of ya some
Sumner somesome maybe the Premier League
once all with with ms madrid something
but it's not really I mean he never got
anywhere with the national team for
example and their own ian is a multiple
Olympic champion with with amenia you
know what's funny I didn't even see that
he can take the night I thought I'm
threatening made on it on g7 but my
opponent didn't didn't get the point
either now rook g5 is a funny move as
Bishop takes a screen g7 made ok so he
gives me the Queen god save the queen
but not in this game he resigned yes
yeah so a second win in yeah I think
being vegetarian or vegan it doesn't
necessarily help you with with losing
weight it should help in many cases but
it's not something that is clearly
related I mean meat is not exactly a um
dad doesn't have that bad nutritional
values Aronian is friends with Kim
Kardashian how is that coming about
I didn't know that clay playing damage
no.4 I should have played fo for the
entertainment I simply forgot about it
and got into my old habits sorry about
that I'm just grinding this position now
good old maroc see bind
ok I'm happy with that
so let's see yeah I've got a good end
game here with the bishop pair in more
space so I'm quite happy with this just
have to see our play this up to a five I
guess so that the night is not having
much space from here though probably I'm
not sure about this probably over to h3
I don't think that Kim Kardashian is a w
GM that sounds funny
okay so it's a very nice position but
I'm not quite sure how to proceed him
this possibly a bishop t4 might be right
but I'm not completely sure about it and
then five it could be a draw I had might
be a draw but I'm not sure
kim kardashian is doing live streams
what is she doing what is what is he
doing on a live stream that people would
watch watching tank tops or something
like that yeah anyway yeah the position
is nice but i am not quite sure if i can
do much he might have 94 simply killing
off the game might happen I wonder maybe
he can just go night you for him I
probably have to take it now I have to
take it you success f5 with the draw I
think I probably have to accept the draw
here
f5 is the only possible way forward but
I think you can play of 6cm that should
be a complete raw or this one yeah
that's a draw
yeah it's a row hmm not much to do okay
let's let's go
okay playing Dinah here who is that San
name no very high rated Grandmaster oh
that's not very maybe I can do this a
little bit more dynamic
but i think it's it's quite it's quite
funny that that Nigel shorter really
doesn't have a good score against women
since that article right he got properly
really properly killed by juventud in
the new zealand enter in the latest he
had Gibraltar he got very very clearly
bitten by a hurry coruña Valley if
that's the right way to pronounce her if
not I'm sorry but I've got trouble with
those with some of those names okay um
night over to see for
yeah I don't know probably I have less
vigorous than Kim Kardashian would maybe
she should lend me some of her outfits
maybe that helped that will help yeah
that position isn't great that I have
him but it's still kind of interesting
we should cheeks mmm yeah okay maybe him
mmm I've got f5 Chad doesn't look good
it's got a knight to e success this is
the biggest biggest issue my nylon c4 is
unstable it's not easy so easy to play
in my book but
probably have to go back huh hmm yeah so
Knight takes d5 he can take we can take
with the rook or what I can click with
the bishop actually okay that's that's a
pretty awful position
hmm I don't really I don't like my
position here the dark squares are
looking terrible yeah he wins a little
bit like I won yesterday against my
opponent g7 huh come on that's a
disaster of the game let's get a new one
and see if I can beat mr. Aladdin hear
that my last opponent dawn I was ready
in two thousand five hundred seventy I
don't see the writing okay so oops got
the got the Spanish exchanged my
opponent is playing in a very boring
fashion okay anyway let's not be too
quick here I can't have to take and to
this prevent Bishop a form I can
absolutely not play chess when listening
to music completely hopeless importance
of playing blind forward for improvement
it's totally unimportant I mean you you
will play you will be able to play
blindfold automatically if you play
better let's say because your skills in
visualizing positions will improve but
it's not you that you train blindfold to
improve that is not happening and that
nobody does it happens automatically
that same
yeah b6 there's this knight takes b6
tactic unfortunately do I have to take
on d5 I don't like to but maybe after
yeah it's still not a big issue it's not
ideal that I have to give up my my
bishop but I still don't think that this
is a huge issue I wants to go to c4 with
the night now I'm not working on another
book and I'm definitely not publishing
another book with a publishing company
if I do something and then i'll publish
on my own i do the printing and so on
organize all that myself but it is not
planned at the moment
yeah it's not an ideal position but
still very little that white has him see
trying to get his rook trapped maybe ah
you want to trade night see that it's
very that's very yeah it's very lame
okay um may I don't have any problem
with every month it's just that whenever
you write a book for publisher and it
really doesn't matter who that is the
the persons who earn most with it are
the publishers and and then the
retailers and the person who earns less
the least of a book is the author and he
has got by far the most work done so
this is just a ridiculous thing so I'm
not going to do this ever again okay
actually has something here with this
very simplistic play I am he has
something he can go g4y does better him
pretty bad game yeah you have to publish
yourself that's the only way to make a
book project worthwhile it's it's a it's
a bunch of work but it's this is at
least somewhat somewhat okay
the publisher is not the most important
not for a chess book because what they
actually do is exactly nothing they take
your script publish it and that's it
they don't do anything else with it yeah
it's it's completely they don't
advertise they don't do nothing not lose
check notice chess I mean ok let's
resign that crap game wow that was bad
that was really bad and he played that
very well that guy I'd like to write
another book but but it's it's it's it's
a complete waste of money if you do it
if you do it with the with a publishing
company it's a complete waste you have
no you have no idea what you earn with
it is it so little it's a complete joke
so it's absolutely no never ever and
really it doesn't it's absolutely
important to it is could be every man or
quality chess or whatever it doesn't
matter it's just a complete waste of
time
yeah I might publish mostly as an e-book
that's very much possible but as I said
there no no clear plans yet yeah you
write the whole book in chessbase
actually and my Ascot Bishop f5 him you
yes the publisher they distribute your
book yeah that's true but this is not
yeah this is not very very simple to do
I mean this is that is very simple to do
to get it get it out in the open
somebody criticizes me making fun of
Republicans I think this is I mean I
mean the last good Republican president
of the United States was probably like
Abraham Lincoln also I don't know anyway
that's politics and I don't feel like
I'm so qualified to give opinions there
and yeah I i lo mein chest bases in ok
software but I have some issues with the
company at times they really do ya do
that Microsoft kind of approach
yeah this is not a very inspiring
position but I still have to play it
okay taking a couple of times on d5 he
has rook to e8 this is actually a little
bit uncomfortable it looks a little bit
it looks very draws recommend for 1st
standard chess tournament what do you
mean recommend for the tournament like
what tournament to play on what training
regimen or something it's a good idea to
get your tactics up to shape definitely
what am I what kind of what kind of
computer am I using um i'm using windows
even though I'm sitting I'm Evan of an
imac but I have to use windows because
of the chest which which sucks a little
bit but what can you do yeah this is a
very draw game yeah come on let's make a
draw in this game it's really nothing
happens here I play another that was
just too boring okay let's see if i can
get a king's gambit in 4 i've got a six
ok here we go one a six ok
so we have some kind of advanced french
with black having played a 6 hmm near
that might it might make some kind of
sense actually is attacking this so I'm
going to protect it we maybe should be
two is very lame and I don't think you
can sacrifice upon maybe with this
that's may be possible okay i can go boo
should be higher that's very slow very
very ambitious player by mr. Elias okay
I'm taking how to do this
okay I'm not quite sure i want to i put
the night on c5 otherwise be three is
not that great I look like Michael
Jackson today wow really that I guess I
never heard that okay so I'm putting a
night on c5 now my development is
excellent I can also play night h4 year
yeah maybe this let's get rid of that
bishop
yeah I think that looks good for whites
yet some some trouble here coordinating
this stuff Queen a4 can just about
answer Queen B 5 even though that costs
the porn doesn't look good um yeah yeah
you can run you can run them you can use
a mac and you can go virtual machine and
so on it does not work well though with
my recording software this is the thing
and unfortunately this is why I have to
use Windows my video recording software
mmm so what here
hey just look see one get everything in
play now you might have knight c6 and
somehow crawl out of this try it for
ruby three yeah I can you know there are
there are a couple of alternatives OBS
or xsplit I can definitely do something
else than what i have but well I need to
be productive and do things and if I toy
around with the software all the time
and never get anything produced and yeah
this is the problem
you have to prepare for a standard time
chess tournament it's a it's a decent
idea to try to get your your tactics and
shape that sets definitely a good advice
yeah increase your your tactical
training makes a lot of sense yeah do do
tactics puzzles things like that also it
makes sense to ya to make sure that you
are kind of okay in your openings that
you're not that you're not completely I
think ever we have to take that you're
not in in bad shape in any of the
marquee took with the f porn yeah that's
often played nowadays maybe maybe maybe
here as well I'm not sure about it that
also weakens this position somewhat
building up some pressure here on the C
file maybe I should have gone to see one
to make a for more likely now see one
would have been better right e seven
days rook CSM
hmm Queen g6 is very threatening so you
might have to go Queen to e8 nope okay
okay I've won a pawn but not yet the
game so what to do here Bishop over to
before I guess I'm not sure queen
evaders if that is such a big threat
probably it is okay it doesn't react to
it Queenie eight yeah still I guess oh
he wants to trade Queens I mean okay
probably doesn't want to but he allows
that so we've got a bishops end game
that should be pretty easily winning
just bring the king of okay
okay and I've got a little bit all the
time disadvantage but it's not much okay
here i can go Bishop e7 but i think i'll
start with this still at Bishop e7 he
might try night to d2 here yes okay
still him so let's see that i can
dominate the night somehow
to go here oh I totally forgot about
that move oh goodness Oh youthful help
help
I'm not sure that I'm winning you this
is the thing I'm winning is night but
unbelievable oh my goodness yeah it's
it's probably a draw but I have two
seconds unbelievable not winning the
game is unbelievable yeah okay there was
a disastrous stream I lost 70 points and
the whole the whole stream okay so um we
are about 16 minutes overtime and I hope
you still enjoyed it I wasn't lacking in
any good shape though yeah I hope it
gets better somehow the next couple of
weeks when I'm not so stressed out from
a technical point of view I think the
YouTube stream work quite fine what we
will change a little bit it's the layout
so that you can see the opponent's
ratings at times you see it if the name
is not too long but it should be on all
the time okay I hope you enjoyed it
anyway and I'm on next week as well bye
bye